let's stick with the phones by which I
mean Discord davidpackman.com slash
Discord extraordinarily
powerful phone calls happening today and
we don't want to miss a minute of it
let's go to Bobby from Jersey Bobby from
Jersey Jersey welcome what's going on
Bobby from Jersey you got to unmute
yourself Michael oh David can you hear
me yes I can
all right is there a specific way that
you go about engaging with conspiracy
uh depends on the specifics I would say
I mean depend depends on where and with
whom
sort of like well I might say
um far-right conspiracy is like queuing
on and like the election results and
whatnot yeah like is there really a way
you can like debunk that or I mean the
problem is that a lot of the people that
believe this stuff aren't actually open
to
thinking of
thinking critically about it and so if
you show them contradictory evidence
they say that evidence is not reliable
or has been planted if you show them the
absence of evidence for what they say
they go right because they're covering
up the evidence for what I believe so
unfortunately with a lot of them there's
really no way to talk them out of it or
even get them to reconsider
yeah that's what I've noticed too all
right David thank you all right thank
you very much there's Bobby from Jersey
yeah I mean unfortunately it's it's
depressing is the reality it's
depressing